christian schubert noch ein statement
geben und danach würden wir in die
fragerunde einsteigen
ich darf das wort an herrn
staatsminister herrmann übergeben wir
haben eine sehr geehrten damen und
herren wir sind natürlich alle sehr
geschockt und tief erschüttert über
dieses schreckliche verbrechen gestern
hier im herzen würzburg dieser brutale
mord die brutalen morde diese schweren
verletzungen
dieses brutale vorgehen des täters ist
denke ich für jeden unbegreiflich
unfassbar dass sich so etwas überhaupt
in unserem land in dieser herrlichen
stadt die wir alle so lieben ereignen
kann die gedanken sind bei den toten bei
den verletzten bei deren angehörigen
wir hoffen und beten dass die die
schwerst verletzt sind die teilweise
noch mit dem leben ringen
das einigermaßen punkt überstehen und
dass sie dann wieder genesen und
gesunden ich möchte mich an dieser
stelle noch einmal herzlich bedanken
zum einen für den sehr raschen und
erfolgreichen einsatz der polizei denn
es ist nicht selbstverständlich dass
innerhalb von zwei minuten nach dem
ersten alarm
von den 110 bereits die ersten
polizeikräfte vor ort waren und das dann
in der tat gelingt gar nicht immer aber
nase zu
so schlimm das alles ist dann doch
wieder bilderbuchmäßig ein beamter den
täter mit einem schuss in den
oberschenkel
entsprechend gestoppt hat und
flugunfähig gemacht hat vielen dank
aber an alle kolleginnen und kollegen
der polizei auch an die die weil man
noch nicht wusste ob ich hier noch mehr
täter unterwegs sein könnten oder welche
gefahren für die würzburger bevölkerung
bestehenden all die vielen polizisten
die zusätzlich dann zum einsatz kamen
auch von außerhalb würzburgs und die mit
dafür gesorgt haben wieder auch ein
gefühl der sicherheit in der würzburger
innenstadt herzustellen bedanke mich
ganz herzlich auch bei den notärzten und
rettungskräften die sehr schnell am ort
war 3 sofort toten war nicht mehr zu
helfen aber es ist von glaube acht
notärzten und vielen rettungssanitätern
ein optimaler einsatz geleistet worden
um die schwer verletzten zu retten und
sich so schnell wie möglich dann auch in
kliniken zu springen nun laufen die
ermittlungen auf hochtouren
ich will dazu meinerseits jetzt keine
kommentierung abgeben sondern dass wir
dieses polizeilicher seite von seiten
der staatsanwaltschaft
gleich berichtet werden wir gehen auf
jeden fall nach gegenwärtig stand haben
wie vor von einem einzeltäter aus es
muss jetzt sieht das tatmotiv geklärt
werden dass die frage wie sah es in dem
der psyche des täters aus und vor allen
dingen wie stark sind islamistische
hintergründe die gestern erkennbar
ja ich bedanke mich auch bei vielen
vielen zeugen fielen würzburgerinnen und
wird sogar andere hier zu gast waren die
sich dann gestern bereits und auch heute
für vernehmungen der polizei zur
verfügung stellen denn es gelingt
wahrscheinlich in einem ausmaßen ist das
sonst häufig nicht der fall ist wirklich
ein sehr vollständiges bild des ganzen
tatgeschehen sich dadurch zu verschaffen
dazu tragen natürlich auch viele
videoaufnahmen bei der auch in einem
reicheren maß als sonst oft zur
verfügung stehen
ich wünsche dieser alles nochmal
natürlich jetzt den verletzten alles
gute ich wünsche auch und das habe ich
gestern ein gespräch mit den
einsatzkräften gespürt wie wünsche auch
den einsatzkräften den zum teil auch
wenn sie schon häufiger mit
schwerverletzten zu tun hatten
trotzdem war schockiert war auf und
tatsächlich auch das zum teil besonders
brutalen vorgehens ist dass man spürt
das war daneben auch für die
einsatzkräfte nicht einfach nur mal so
wie sonst jeden tag sondern dass wir
auch für viele auch einsatzkräfte die
schon vieles gewohnt seine besondere
belastung auch denen wünsche ich von
herzen alles gute
ich habe die bemerkungen gestern und
auch heute noch mal den
ministerpräsidenten intensiv informiert
über die geschehen ist sie hier
er hat bei der veranstaltung in nürnberg
heute auch sehr deutlich sein mitgefühl
und unsere tiefe betroffenheit insgesamt
zum ausdruck gebracht und ich habe auch
sein dank
von markus söder gerade auch nochmal
hier den ganzen kolleginnen und kollegen
hier die sie mit am tisch sitzen zum
ausdruck gebracht auch der
bundesinnenminister horst seehofer hat
sich heute früh von mir mal im detail
informieren lassen wie sich die lage im
moment darstellt und verfolgt natürlich
die weiteren ermittlungen ja auch mit
großer aufmerksamkeit ich wäre dankbar
wenn jetzt von seiten der polizei und
der staatsanwaltschaft der momentanen
ermittlungsstand wiedergegeben würde ich
stehe ihnen danach gerne für fragen zur
verfügung
wir sagen ja dann geht die betroffenheit
die hat auch die unterfränkische polizei
eingenommen ich war die nacht über
draußen fahrt habe mir das angeschaut
und war bei haben verletzte gesehen und
ab tode gesehen und vor allem auch die
schrecklichen videos eigentlich noch
kommen möchte ich möchte aber vor allem
an erster stelle
auch allen danken die mitgeholfen haben
den einsatz heute nacht zu bewältigen
rettungskräfte einsatzkräfte feuerwehren
sind schon angesprochen worden
ich möchte noch ganz bewusst weil ich
auch hier
die videos angesehen habe und die
berichte der kollegin einen herzlichen
dank an alle bürgerinnen und bürger
aussprechen
die plötzlich gestern nachmittag auch in
eine extremsituation gekommen sind und
dort mitgeholfen haben den täter dann
auch in die kasse zu treiben und die
kollegen dann auch hier ihren einsatz
gut machen konnten
nach der schrecklichen tat im juli 2016
ist jetzt fast genau fünf jahre er in
der region haben wir als
sicherheitsbehörden und als polizei
natürlich noch mal das eine oder andere
in unseren konzeptionen verbessert dass
wir ihnen dann auch in dem zusammenhang
mit teilen wollen
aber zunächst zum geschehensablauf
gestern die chronologie und punkt 17 uhr
hat der täter ein kaufhaus in der
kaiserstraße in würzburg betreten es
dann in die abteilung für haushaltswaren
gegangen und hat sich dort von einer
verkäuferin beraten lassen hat gefragt
wo sind die messer wir wissen
insbesondere anhand von den
videoaufzeichnungen dass der täter sich
aus einer auslage eines der messer
gegriffen und dann unvermittelt mehrfach
auf verkäuferin eingestochen hatte diese
wurde dadurch so schwer verletzt dass
sie noch dort ihren verletzungen erlegen
ist
im weiteren verlauf griff der täter
weitere personen im kaufhaus mit dem
messer an
dabei bildete er mit stiche zwei weitere
frauen und 17 uhr 4 gegen dann der
notruf über einen messerangriff bei der
polizei einsatzzentrale in würzburg ein
die kolleginnen der einsatzzentrale
haben sofort alle verfügbaren
einsatzkräfte an dem pariser platz
geordert und nach rund zwei minuten nach
der mitteilung zeitweise die ersten
polizeikräfte vor ort sind dort aufgrund
den mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger die
hier den täter schon in die enge
getrieben hatten
aufmerksam geworden auf diese ansammlung
in der obertorstraße ecke kolpingstraße
konnte der täter dann durch die
streifenbesatzung gestellt werden
der täter hielt zu diesem zeitpunkt das
messer in der hand bewegte sich in
richtung der eingesetzten polizeibeamten
und durch einsatz der schusswaffe konnte
der täter durch einen gezielten schuss
in den oberschenkel gestoppt sowohl
frucht als auch angriffs unfähig gemacht
werden und in gewahrsam genommen werden
anschließend erfolgte die medizinische
versorgung die polizeilichen maßnahmen
im bereich des pariser platzes waren
zunächst natürlich eine weiträumige
absperrung eine räumung der komplette
nahverkehr über die verkehrsachse
juliuspromenade kam zum erliegen
darüber hinaus hat die polizei eine
überregionale führungsstruktur aufgebaut
das polizeipräsidium unterfranken hat
die einsatzleitung übernommen
das würde kräfte sammelstelle
eingerichtet sie haben ja alle auch
mitbekommen dass sehr viele kräfte
insgesamt im einsatz waren wir hatten
heute nacht obwohl der täter schon
festgenommen war 300 rund 300
einsatzkräfte im einsatz
in unmittelbarer nähe zum tatort in
einem dortigen lokal wurde
betreuungsstelle für zeugen und
angehörige auch eingerichtet
kräfte der polizei einschließlich des
rettungsdienstes die theaterarbeit und
die spurensicherung ist unverzüglich
übernommen worden und die
kriminalpolizei und den bayerischen
landeskriminalamt was etwas gedauert hat
war dann die identifizierung des täters
die muss natürlich sicher sein
mittels fingerabdrücke die wohnanschrift
des täters wurde nach weiteren
beweismitteln durchsucht
wir haben die bevölkerung insbesondere
über die sozialen medien in einer
rassischen pressemeldung über die es
über die erkenntnisse informiert und es
bestand nach der festnahme des täters
keine gefahr mehr für die
hinweise auf weitere täter bestehen zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt nach wie vor nicht
mehr konnten aber in der ersten phase
und haben das natürlich nicht gemacht
ein zweiter ausschließen
daher natürlich auch die einsatzkräfte
die hier aufklärungsarbeit im gesamten
stadtgebiet geleistet an
wir haben grundsätzlich jetzt zur
bewältigung derartiger einsatzlagen nach
dem anschlag 2016 so genannte konzeption
lebens petroli einsatzlagen entwickelt
die wird später unser ein kollege martin
wilhelm noch einige punkte daraus
vorstellen wird es heute nacht
ausgesehen hat wir hatten ja auch
trainingsinhalte dann die angepasst
worden sind zudem war und ist unser ziel
auf die erwartungen und bedürfnisse
natürlich der angehörigen und opfer
einzugehen beispielsweise durch
entsprechende gleichbleibende
polizeiliche ansprechpartner und
entsprechende betreuung auch dies
jeweils erfolgt und ich darf an dieser
stelle dann an unsere vizepräsident
einmal den willen übergeben der ihn zu
den verschiedenen einsatzabschnitten die
gebildet worden sind und insbesondere
die konzeption nach erläuterungen geben
[Musik]
ein grüß gott ich war heute nacht mit
führungs übernahme der
gesamteinsatzleiter des sehr intensiven
einsatzgeschehens ich möchte ihnen ein
paar eckwerte zu dem vorhandenen konzept
auch gerne mit mitteilen
es gibt ein konzept bei der bayerischen
polizei lebensbedrohliche einsatzlagen
das ja allein schon durch die
beweglichkeit deutlich macht in welcher
dimension wir uns bewegen
diese konzepte werden bei uns
standardmäßig weiter entwickelt anhand
der lage erkenntnissen usw
bei diesem einsatz heute nacht zu
gestern abend und heute nacht möglich
drei punkte herausgreifen einmal das
thema wie geht polizei am tatort vor
was machen wir zur sicherung einer stadt
letztendlich und auch das thema
betreuung von opfern angehörigen weil es
ein ganz zentraler punkt in der
bayerischen polizei seit geraumer zeit
ist mit festen strukturen und kräften
bei einer lage wie sie gestern
losgebrochen ist weil diese formulieren
darf ist am anfang die information die
gesicherte information eines unserer
größten herausforderungen was liegt denn
vor was haben wir hier in dem bereich
wusste mir durch den notruf erste
erkenntnisse und von daher war uns klar
es ist eine sehr brisante lage insoweit
erfolgen in dem konzept das ziel einen
bewaffneten täter möglichst schnell zu
lokalisieren die weiteren tathandlungen
zu unterbinden und den täter
entsprechend auch festzunehmen
das dient auch ins unter dem zweck dass
die bevölkerung in dem bereich einen
möglichst hohen schutz genießen soll
durch die einsatzkräfte
diese erste schwierige phase die auch
sehr gut von der polizeiinspektion
würzburg statt angegangen worden ist ist
geprägt von diesem informationsdefizit
aber auch von einer lagebewertung die
zugesichert information führt und die
höchste priorität ist es möglichst
schnell eine hohe anzahl von
einsatzkräften vor ort zu bekommen
das ist in dem fall auch gelungen
möglichst viele verfügbare streifen
kräfte vor ort zu bewegen und auch sehr
schnell den täter zu lokalisieren
verbunden ist es auch mit entsprechendem
konsequenten polizeilichen vorgehen
entwicklung des täters denn es muss
unterbunden werden dass der täter
weitere taten in dieser qualität begehen
konnte alle verfügbaren streifen waren
vor ort
es wurden 1 teams gebildet der täter
elektrisiert und es endlich auch nach
dem schusswaffengebrauch und man sieht
ja auch das messer waren noch in seiner
hand und er war noch handlungs und
angriffs fähig bis dahin konnte den
schusswaffengebrauch der täter gestoppt
werden und die einwirkungsmöglichkeiten
von ihm wurden damit reduziert der
gefahrenbereich lässt sich in so einem
zeitraum noch nicht abschließend
abschätzen
deswegen haben wir sehr stark die stadt
würzburg die kernstadt insbesondere mit
starken kräften in zug stärke durch
unsere einsatzzüge von uns aber auch der
bereitschaftspolizei entsprechend
gesichert die kräfte im stadtgebiet
disloziert mobil und stationär verteilt
haben die sicherung des stadtgebiets
aber auch für mögliche weitere tagen
mögliche weitere tatorte mit
interventionen kräften versehen die
schnell und möglichst präzise auf
weitere tat handlung die mir zu dem
zeitpunkt noch nicht ausschließen
konnten einwirken hätten sollen
dieser umfangreiche raum schutz den er
gefahren haben haben wir auch auch nicht
erhalten über die nacht und wird auch
weiter im stadtgebiet mit starker
polizeilicher präsenz sichtbar sein
diese innovationskräfte waren verfügbar
das ist auch bei uns durch die
hervorragende ausstattung wir haben
sowohl für den schutz der kolleginnen
kollegen entsprechende schutzwesten und
helme und vergleichbare es werden aber
auch die entsprechende bewaffnung um
hier auch aktiv gegen noch agierende
täter entsprechend vorgehen zu können
die einsatzzüge haben letztendlich dann
der stadtgebiet so weit gesichert
auch als zeichen für die bevölkerung das
polizei in einer starken präsenz da ist
die betreuung von opfern angehörigen hat
einen hohen stellenwert weil wir wissen
und diesem eindruck können wir uns auch
selber nicht verschließen wenn man
nachts diesen einsatz momentan einmal
abschließt welche persönlichen
eindrücken mitnimmt deswegen haben wir
speziell dafür eine eigene konzeption
die bayernweit umgesetzt ist wir haben
betreuungsteams innerhalb der polizei
auch beim polizeipräsidium unterfranken
diese betreuungsteams wurden gestern in
großer stärke mit 30 einsatzkräften
aufgerufen wurden aus ganz unterfranken
zusammengezogen und haben dann sich um
die opfer
die angehörigen gekümmert haben sie
informiert aus erster hand waren als
ansprechpartner zur verfügung haben
unterstützt bei allen fragestellungen
und verbunden mit den fachdiensten der
rettungsdienste also vor allem der
krisen in der winterzeit
krisenintervention gemeinsam diese
ansprechbarkeit für die opferangehörigen
dargestellt der opferschutz hat hier
große priorität auch in verbindung mit
den wiener staatsanwaltschaft
das war drei wesentliche punkte dieser
einsatz ist noch wesentlich größer
aufgebaut habe ich wollte ihnen nur mal
einen gewissen schwerpunkt der bei uns
in dieser ersten großen phase von
zentraler bedeutung ist noch mal kurz
darstellen
vielen dank
ja meine damen und herren auch von
meiner seite aus groß gott ich bin
leiter der kriminalpolizeiinspektion
würzburg und mir sind in einem solchen
fall natürlich auch immer sehr gefordert
der kriminaldauerdienst der rund um die
uhr da ist er die erstmaßnahmen vor ort
aufgenommen
gleichzeitig haben wir natürlich sehr
viele kräfte der kriminalpolizei
alarmiert und verständigt das hat uns
dann letztendlich auch in die lage
versetzt die ermittlungen sehr schnell
zügig und zielgerichtet durchzuführen
insbesondere sind natürlich für die
polizei wichtig die identität des täters
festzustellen
gleichzeitig ist genauso zu verfolgen
haben wir weitere täter tatverdächtige
oder haben wir es mit einem allein
handelnden täter zu tun
die sichtung des überwachungs materials
der überwachungskameras ein wesentlicher
punkt und das ist hier in diesem rahmen
schon angeklungen der hat auch
wesentlich dazu beigetragen dass wir
relativ schnell ein ziemlicher
sicherheit sagen konnten dass es sich um
einen allein handelnden täter handelt
wir haben dann auch sehr schnell vor ort
kräfte verlagert und eine zeugen
sammelstelle eingerichtet
also das ist für uns möglich war eine
sehr hohe anzahl von vernehmungen von
zeugen gleich vor ort durchzuführen was
natürlich auch zu einer heilung der
sachlage führt in diesem zusammenhang
darf ich nicht unerwähnt lassen die
offenheit der bevölkerung die
bereitschaft zur zusammenarbeit
auch der polizei räumlichkeiten für eine
solche zeugen sammelstelle zur verfügung
zu stellen
das ist ein sehr wichtiger punkt der uns
auch die arbeit erleichtert und
letztendlich auch mit zum erfolg
beiträgt die ermittlungen und das kann
man wörtlich nehmen haben am gestrigen
tag sind am gestrigen tage rund um die
uhren auf hochtouren gelaufen
das ganze natürlich unter enger
einbeziehung der rechtsmedizin und der
staatsanwaltschaft die auch bei dem
einsatz auch persönlich vertreten und
zugegen war
aktuell laufen natürlich die
ermittlungen noch weiter
trotz des großen personaleinsatzes ist
es natürlich ein sehr umfangreicher
ermittlungsvorgang der noch einige zeit
in anspruch nehmen wird
in diesem zusammenhang darf ich auch um
zeugenhinweise bittet die es uns
ermöglichen insbesondere die vortat
phase zu erhellen wo hat sich der täter
vor der tatbegehung bewegt mit wem hat
er sich bewegt das ist für die weiteren
ermittlungen natürlich sehr wichtig in
diesem zusammenhang darf ich auch auf
dieses telefon geschaltete telefon
letztendlich vom bayerischen
landeskriminalamt verweisen wo man
kostenfrei derartige mitteilungen machen
kann
auch das medien- upload portal der
polizei ist
eine wichtige grundlage wo wir gerade in
der heutigen zeit wo viele jüngere oder
jung gebliebene menschen unterwegs sind
und mit dem handy gewisse sequenzen
aufnehmen dass die uns daher sehr
schnell zur verfügung gestellt werden
können
das ermittlungsverfahren selbst wird
heute von uns noch an das
landeskriminalamt übergeben
zu diesem zweck sind bereits heute in
den frühen morgenstunden mehrere
kollegen vom landeskriminalamt zu uns
nach würzburg gestoßen
und wir arbeiten momentan zusammen mit
dem ziel das wir natürlich einen
gemeinsamen wissens und kenntnisstand
haben dass auch das ermittlungsverfahren
nahtlos übergeben werden kann
die ermittlungen werden natürlich
insbesondere und das liegt natürlich
auch in der natur der sache
zu einem möglichen politischen
hintergrund geführt und die kollegen
insbesondere vom landeskriminalamt
arbeiten da auch in sehr enger
abstimmung mit der staatsanwaltschaft
zusammen
das ist für mich ein stichwort das ich
dass gott an die staatsanwaltschaft
übergeben möchte vielen dank
ja mein name ist wolfgang und gleich mit
der generalstaatsanwalt in bamberg und
auch zuständig damit für würzburg auch
uns angehörigen der betroffenen
staatsanwaltschaften sind die ereignisse
des gestrigen abends sehr an die nieren
gegangen
wie gedenken der opfer wir fühlen mit
den verletzten und den angehörigen der
opfer
auch ich will meinen dank richten
zunächst einmal an die bürger
die beherzt eingegriffen haben und die
zwei bis die polizei aber überbrückt
haben und so mit dafür gesorgt haben
dass deppe dargestellt werden konnte
auch die bereitschaft sich als zeuge zur
verfügung zu stellen verdient den dank
der dank geht aber auch an die
eingesetzten kräfte der polizei
rettungsdienste und meinen kolleginnen
und kollegen der staatsanwaltschaften
gemeinsam haben diese kräfte es
geschafft sehr schnell
diesen stand der ermittlungen gehen wir
jetzt haben und den stand der sicherheit
für die bürgerinnen und bürger würzburgs
sicherzustellen
ich will ihnen nun einige erkenntnisse
oder die erkenntnisse die wir zur person
des täters haben mitteilen es handelt
sich bei dem beschuldigten um einen
24-jährigen somalischen
staatsangehörigen der seit mai 2015 im
bundesgebiet sich aufhält er steht unter
subsidiären schutz im rahmen eines
asylverfahrens so dass sein aufenthalt
in der bundesrepublik deutschland legal
ist
er ist aktuell gemeldet in einem
städtischen obdachlosenwohnheim in
würzburg nach dem derzeitigen stand der
ermittlungen ist er nicht vorbelastet
dennoch seien im jahr 2021 einige
verhaltensauffälligkeiten festgestellt
worden
so ist er in januar 2021 mit
mitbewohnern und verwaltern der
obdachlosenunterkunft in einen verbalen
streit geraten und hat im rahmen dieses
streites zu einem küchenmesser gegriffen
und dieses bedrohliche in der hand
gehalten es gab aber keine tätlichen
angriffe und auch keine verletzung
gegen den beschuldigten wurde wegen
dieser ereignisse ein
ermittlungsverfahren wegen bedrohung und
beleidigung das sind die
straftatbestände die da möglicherweise
realisiert wurden eingeleitet und es
erfolgte eine vorübergehende einweisung
in eine psychiatrische anstalt
des weiteren wurde im märz ein hinweis
eines anderen asylbewerbers überprüft
den dieser im januar 2021 oder bis märz
wurde der überprüfte in dieser im januar
2021 gegeben hat wonach der beschuldigte
im jahr 2015 2016 im jahreswechsel am
telefon gesagt haben soll dass der
beschuldigte als zwölfjähriger in
somalia straftaten begangen haben soll
diese prüfungen wurden eingestellt da
sich die erkenntnis sie nicht
verifizieren ließen und darüber hinaus
der beschuldigte bei der tat zeit erst
zwölf jahre alt gewesen ist und die
strafbarkeit möglichkeit bestände zu
verfolgen beginnt erst ab 14 jahren im
juni 22 kam es dann zu einer belästigung
eines verkehrsteilnehmers in der
innenstadt von würzburg
da hat er beschuldigte ein verstörtes
verhalten mit psychischen
auffälligkeiten gezeigt im rahmen dieser
auffälligkeiten wurde der beschuldigte
abermals in eine psychiatrische anstalt
eingewiesen
dort allerdings wegen fehlender vielen
behandlungsbedarf ist nach einem tag
wieder entlassen
das war soweit die erkenntnisse die wir
zur person des beschuldigten haben und
ich bitte jetzt meinen kollegen
leitenden oberstaatsanwalt der
staatsanwaltschaft würzburg den angriff
die erkenntnisse zur vorführung des
beschuldigten in den mitzuteilen
dankeschön
ja meine damen und herren der
beschuldigte wurde heute am späten
vormittag dem ermittlungsrichter am
amtsgericht würzburg vorgeführt
der ermittlungsrichter hat als ergebnis
dieser vorführung einen haftbefehl gegen
den beschuldigten erlassen
und zwar wegen vollendeten mordes in
drei fällen wegen versuchten mordes und
gefährlicher körperverletzung in sechs
weiteren fällen und wegen vorsätzlicher
körperverletzung in einem weiteren fall
der beschuldigte hat anlässlich dieser
vorführung keine angaben zur sache
gemacht
er befindet sich inzwischen in einer
bayerischen justizvollzugsanstalt
sehr geehrte damen und herren mitten an
einem friedlichen freitagnachmittag
geschieht eine solche gewalttat in einem
würzburger kaufhaus in der innenstadt
menschen werden brutal ihres lebens
beraubt und zahlreiche schwerverletzte
werden in den krankenhäusern behandelt
das trifft eine stadt eine
stadtgesellschaft und auch mich
persönlich mitten ins herz
insbesondere natürlich auch dadurch wird
zum zweiten mal im laufe eines
jahrzehntes durch zufall fügung oder wie
auch immer schauplatz einer solchen
straftat
werden und dadurch kommen natürlich bei
uns hier in würzburg aber auch natürlich
auch über würzburg hinaus erinnerungen
daran natürlich hoch ich möchte zunächst
einmal meinen dank artikulieren
nämlich dass die polizei und das kam
hier jetzt zum ausdruck sehr schnell
durch ihre präsenz am ort noch eine
fortsetzung dieser gewalttat dann
vereiteln konnte auch durch den
couragierten das couragierte
einschreiten aus der situation heraus
ohne absprache von bürgern von passanten
konnte ein stück weit wie man den
filmaufnahmen entnimmt das weitere
letzten endes ein stück weit
ja der täter ein stück weit in seinem
bewegungsdrang eingeschränkt werden wie
es eben die polizei eingetroffen ist das
nötigt einem allergrößten respekt ab
weil die menschen die sich dort
engagiert haben die sich dort eingesetzt
haben
die haben das unter dem einsatz ihres
eigenen lebens und lebensgefahr gemacht
unabgesprochen aber auch die ersthelfer
die an den ort gekommen sind
da waren auch einige kollegen dabei die
ich auch vor wenigen jahren schon bei
jeder anderen schrecklichen gewalttat
gesehen habe waren sofort zur stelle und
haben geholfen nach kräften
bei allen diesen bin ich dankbar weil
dieser einsatz sehr schnell und sehr
professionell auch durchgeführt worden
ist werden gerade in den vergangenen
jahren auch entsprechende koordinierungs
absprachen zwischen polizei feuerwehr
und rettungsdiensten getroffen und das
hat sich jetzt auch entsprechend auch
ausgezahlt
das was uns umtreibt das ist erst mal
dieses gedenken jetzt und da das
mitgefühl mit den opfern mit den
angehörigen die jetzt bangen und leiden
und das trifft unsere stadtgesellschaft
eben im kern
wir suchen auch im moment nach
geeigneten formen damit umzugehen
zunächst wird es morgen um 15.30 eine
gedenkfeier für die opfer der gewalttat
im würzburger dom geben an der neben dem
bischof der stadt würzburg die
evangelische regionalbischof dr josef
schuster aber auch vertreter der
muslimischen gemeinden hier in der stadt
teilnehmen werden es gibt auch und das
kann ich auch verstehen eine
pressemitteilung unseres ausländer und
integrationsbeirat der stadt würzburg
weil natürlich auch wenn im moment keine
aussagen tiefergehenden zur motivation
und zum hintergrund getroffen werden
können natürlich die sage auch der
ausländischen bevölkerung in unserer
stadt ist dass sie in einem
generalverdacht hineinkommen wir haben
auch zahlreiche somalia hier in der
stadt wohnen und das dann letzten endes
weil ein somalia der täter war ein
rückschluss angestellt
und das denke ich dem gilt es ganz klar
und entschieden entgegen zu treten
das eben hier keine pauschalen
verurteilung stattfinden es handelt sich
nach jetzigem erkenntnisstand um einen
einzeltäter
wir haben zwar gehört aus zeugenaussagen
dass der täter ali akbar gerufen hat
haben mag ich weiß es nicht genau wissen
aber auch dass er in psychologischer
behandlung war und verhaltensauffällig
war und das gilt es entsprechend in den
nächsten wochen auch zu klären
insofern gilt meine sorge neben neben
den angehörigen auch den frieden
natürlich in unserer stadtgesellschaft
dem es auch zu bewahren gilt dann
würzburg ist eine friedliche stadt und
steht auch dafür in allen ja
ausdifferenzierung und vielen vielen
organisationen und einrichtungen und
religionsgemeinschaften die sich dafür
stark machen
auch wird morgen herr ab morgen und hat
montag im würzburger rathaus ein
kondolenzbuch entsprechend ausliegen
wir sind hier sehr betroffen
wir suchen den geeigneten umgang
entsprechend damit das ist das was ich
im moment zu dieser schrecklichen tat
ihnen sagen kann
die geschehnisse gehört sie haben unsere
erkenntnisse gehört die wir bisher
zusammengetragen haben da stellt sich
natürlich die frage wie geht es jetzt
weiter
ich werde diesen bat die polizei wir
haben die da war für arbeit noch nicht
abgeschlossen
das ist ein sehr großer tatort
beziehungsweise mehrere tatorte weil
sich selber eine gewisse strecke gezogen
hat die wird heute mit sicherheit den
ganzen tag noch andauern
es werden dann weitere ermittlungen
notwendig seien beispielsweise auch wenn
die auswertung wir haben zwei hält ist
auch sichergestellt
die sind zu übersetzen die sind aus zu
werden
die vielen daten die hier enthalten sind
und wir müssen weitere vernehmungen
machen wir haben heute nacht man am
heutigen tag bereits rund 50 vernehmung
schriftlich durchgeführt um diesen
erkenntnisstand den wir ihnen jetzt
heute präsentiert haben
jetzt präsentiert haben zu haben das
landesamt können das vorgetragen
übernimmt die weiteren ermittlungen das
vorauskommando ist seit heute nacht
schon hier der präsident des
landeskriminalamts der happy cat ist
jetzt heute auch vor ort gekommen
es ist hier dass die übernahme an
betrifft das sind auch erfahrungen aus
der vergangenheit keine eile geboten das
muss sorgfältig gemacht werden ohne
informationsverlust deshalb
vorauskommando einfließen lassen und
dann gemeinsam zunächst weiterarbeiten
und dann geht es über die zuständigkeit
für den schusswaffeneinsatz die liegt
beim landeskriminalamt schon seit heute
nacht das ist aber auch etwas ganz
berlin mäßiges bewährtes seit vielen
jahren machen
das landeskriminalamt als neutrale
stelle bei jedem schutzmatten einsatz
das sind die nächsten schritte die im
polizeibereich getätigt werden und ich
werde übergeben weil natürlich auch auf
seiten der staatsanwaltschaft hier
zuständigkeiten dann fließen
und zwar nicht nur die einzel 1 vielen
dank meine damen und herren
nachdem wir es hier mit einer amok lage
zu tun hatten hat die staatsanwaltschaft
würzburg nach der wirkung des
haftbefehls und nach inhaftierung des
beschuldigten
das ermittlungsverfahren abgegeben und
zwar an die für derartige fälle
zuständige abteilung zeit der
generalstaatsanwaltschaft münchen
das heißt das verfahren wird
mittlerweile nicht mehr bei der
staatsanwaltschaft würzburg geführt was
bei uns noch verbleibt das ist die
überprüfung des schusswaffengebrauchs
durch den polizeibeamten wieder herr
polizeipräsident kallert bereits gesagt
hat überprüfen wir hier gemeinsam mit
dem landeskriminalamt die rechtmäßigkeit
dieses schusswaffen einsatzes wobei ich
auch klarstellen möchte dass zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt keinerlei hinweise
dafür bestehen dass dieser
schusswaffengebrauch nicht rechtmäßig
gewesen sein sollte
im gegenteil also für mich sieht es eher
so aus als ob dieser polizeibeamte hier
alles richtig gemacht hat
danke
ja
ja dann schlage ich vor dass ich etwas
sage hinsichtlich der einreise und das
bka nach würzburg gekommen ist
leider ermittlungen zu der anderen frage
und die geräte ja machen wir dann also
der täter ist eingereist erstein 30 im
bundesgebiet am 6 mai 2015 die erste
reise ist erfolgt beim kampf außenstelle
chemnitz
anschließend ist es übernommen worden
aufgrund umzug landratsamt
erzgebirgskreis es dann übernommen
worden jahr 2016 von der stadtverwaltung
in düsseldorf im jahr 2009 10 war
zuständig stadtverwaltung in chemnitz
anschließend war da noch ein vorzug und
ab 14 9 2009 10 war er in würzburg und
die stadtverwaltung in würzburg
zuständig es ist brauchen schon
mitgeteilt worden dass er asylantrag
gestellt hatte der status von ihm
sogenannten subsidiären schutz machen
als wie gesetz das hat sich legal hier
in deutschland aufgehalten und
angekündet und beruf würde weiter max ja
zu der frage ob sich das tatgeschehen
ausschließlich in dem
geschäft abgespielt hat muss ich sagen
nein der täter hat das geschäft
verlassene es in den öffentlichen raum
gegangen
auf die straße hat dort weiter passanten
und menschen mit dem messer attackiert
auch die von ihnen angesprochenen die
sparkasse auch hier war er zugegen
aus dem grund ist die tatortarbeit
natürlich für uns auch sehr umfangreich
weil sich der tatort im öffentlichen
raum doch über eine größere strecke
zieht die brille frage war nach der
identität der eingeschnitten sind also
zur identität der bürger die
eingeschritten sind die haben wir in
erster linie auch durch die sogenannten
uploads also videosequenzen die
hochgeladen worden sind ob wir da alle
haben das kann ich jetzt nicht mit
sicherheit sagen es ist allerdings so
dass das mit sicherheit auch leute dabei
sind die bei unserer zeugen anlaufstelle
angelaufen sind und dort als zeuge
vernommen wurden
ich habe die frage jetzt nicht ganz
rechts gegen neue um die frage der wäre
übrigens gerade von niemand extra
hingewiesen dass die übertragung jeweils
die frage stelle nicht zu hören sind
also das müsste man auch noch micro
mäßig irgendwie organisieren aber zu der
frage ist ging darum nochmal
letztendlich ab inwieweit sich der
islamistische hintergründe in
irgendeiner weise habe ich verstanden
habe konkretisiert hat ich habe da
gestern ja darauf hingewiesen dass es
und das ist so weit klarer die
zeugenaussage eines zeugen in dem
kaufhaus gibt der denke ich glaubwürdig
erklärt der täter habe da alle berufen
ansonsten ja wäre ich dankbar
wenn das nochmal so weit vielleicht
erkennst würde
der täter ist ja inzwischen vernommen
worden
dort hat es weitere vorsichtige hinweise
gegeben und das haben diese
durchsuchungen stattgefunden
aber das ganze denken lässt sich so ist
es bei mir ankommen heute noch nicht
abschließend sagen sondern bedarf eben
einer weiteren und ja natürlich der
weiteren ermittlungen in der weiteren
auswertungen usw
ich will nur weil wir daher auch schon
erfahrungen in anderen fällen in bayern
hatten an dieser stelle nochmal auch
wenn ich kein kriminologe und kein
psychologe bin darauf hinweisen dass die
hinreise auf vielleicht eine radikale
gesinnung in dem fall islamismus und die
hinweise auf mögliche psychische
probleme des täters schließen sich nicht
gegenseitig aus
wir haben in der vergangenheit journal
debatten in den ferien gehabt nach dem
motto es muss krampfhaft gesucht werden
in welche schublade wir gehört menschen
sind nun mal so ich kann das in dem fall
jetzt heute noch überhaupt nicht
beurteilen ich will nur darauf hinweisen
es ist nicht die frage ob psychische
probleme oder radikale gesinnung oder
gleich und wir wissen weder das eine
noch das andere im moment sicher aber
ich bin auch schon an dieser stelle
darauf hinweisen ist schließlich auch
nicht gegenseitig aus ist kann menschen
geben dann irgendwo beides zumindest
ansatzweise vorhanden ist aber das muss
gegenstand der weiteren ermittlungen
sein
wenn sich jetzt der kaller zu den
meldungen
auch insoweit ergänzen als nicht nur die
aussage von dem kaufhausdetektiv das
gehört hat im kaufhaus sondern auch bei
beamten ist auch alaba gefallen und sie
hat geäußert worden
insgesamt und alles andere müssen wir
jetzt aus werden insbesondere die handy
auswertung was es da noch drauf was
ergibt sich danach was unsere minister
gerade ausgeführt hatte schließlich
nicht aus dass gibt es auch einige
hinweise welche methode nur hinweise
weil wenn ich video anzuschauen
zielgerichtet vorgegangen ist und andere
sachen
dann muss man die einzelheiten hat ihre
prüfen und dann miteinander bewerten und
an zu einem schlüssigen ergebnisse am
schluss zu kommen und das ergebnis kann
nur am schluss der ermittlungen stehen
alles andere ist jetzt mit einem
zwischenstand verifizierte angaben weil
es kommen verschiedene informationen zu
der identität oder zumindest alter
geschlecht der opfer sagen dann gibt es
erste meldungen dass tatsächlich bei den
durchsuchungen in diesem obdachlosenheim
belastendes material gefunden wurde
vielleicht können sie dann auch ein
bisschen klarer einfach auch darauf
eingehen was man da gefunden hat und
warum man möglicherweise doch eine
radikale gesinnung in betracht zieht
hört zum belastenden material und zur
durchsuchungsaktion kann der anwender
am besten etwas sagen natürlich wir
haben das gesamte heim und das ganze
objekt der zucht und was aufgefunden
worden ist sagt er könne ja wir haben in
dem heim natürlich
ein handy gefunden was noch ausgewertet
werden muss
die auswertung dieser handys gestaltet
sich sehr schwierig und aufwändig da die
nachrichten die darauf sind natürlich
nicht in deutscher sprache sind sondern
wir brauchen hierfür extra dolmetscher
die uns da weiterhelfen
heute kamen auch der hinweise ein dass
auch noch dort schrift materialen mit
hassbotschaften wären dieses material
haben wir ebenfalls sichergestellt es
ist aber noch nicht ausgewertet und
deshalb kann es auch noch nicht
verifiziert werden
ob das tatsächlich so ist und in welchem
zusammenhang ist mit der tat zu sehen
ist
ja uns zur identität der getöteten wir
haben drei getöteten frauen geboren 39
96 und 1972 alle drei waren in dem
geschäft und wir haben die schwer
verletzten personen überwiegend hatte es
insgesamt sind geschädigte die frauen 81
geboren 2010 geboren
94 und 64
dann noch außerhalb des geschäftes zwei
eine frau 2005 geborgen und ein assist
1947 geboren im bereich der sparkasse
[Musik]
wer spekulation
es ist wirklich wie nacht schon
aufgefallen aber da müssen wir jetzt die
gesamten bundes lagen aus werden über
siege gestellt haben ob da ein
zusammenhang ist oder ob das oder
umständen auch zufall sein kann
vertriebschefs hat zdf
ich wollte mal fragen sie haben ja
erläutert das an verschiedenen stellen
er verhaltensauffällig wurde der täter
gibt es kann man sagen haben wir auch
mit den ärzten gesprochen gab es da zu
nehmende verhaltensauffälligkeiten war
dass gewalt welche in welche richtung
ging das auch bei diesem
verkehrsteilnehmer was waren das für
aussagen also dass man sich mal ein bild
machen kann wie es in dem kopf dieses
menschen aus gesehen hat das würde uns
doch sehr interessieren um ein bisschen
ein bild zu bekommen
ja das gleiche versuchen wir jetzt auch
dementsprechend nachzuvollziehen das
heißt die fälle werden jetzt natürlich
noch mal geprüft noch mal aufgeregt aber
wir haben jetzt keine zufällige oder
keine zunehmenden auffälligkeiten bei
ihm insgesamt knapp die fälle die im
januar war die generalstaatsanwaltschaft
vorgetragen hat sind unter der
überschrift bedrohung gelaufen aber es
hat durchaus auch ein messer eine rolle
gespielt aber in einem ganz anderen
zusammenhang beispielsweise keine wäsche
die angriffe keine verletzungen sondern
die eine bedrohung war auf einer
entfernung von 20 meter zwischen opfer
und täter und die zweite war bei einer
auseinandersetzung in der küche war dann
ein küchenmesser mit einer länge der
schneide von 10 cm im griff
hat aber daran die auch mich auf einen
menschen wirklich losgegangen ist aber
dass man beide hin nachfragen da muss
man nach hagen
man muss schauen was ist dann etwas nach
und es wirklich aufzuklären und am
schluss ein vollständiges pizzeria und
auch des im juni 2021 was noch zu der
eintägigen unterbringung in der
psychiatrischen anstalt geführt hat ist
ohne jede gewalt das einfach in meinem
pkw von dem er sich mitnehmen hat lassen
nicht ausgestiegen und hat sich insofern
auffällig gezeigt dass dann zur
einweisung in die psychiatrische anstalt
gefüttert abgelehnt werden würde und
deshalb irgendwie aufgeregt ist also mir
zur jetzigen zeitpunkt nicht bekannt
schauen wir noch recht ist im augenblick
nicht
das verfahren war nicht mehr offen
sondern er hat den sogenannten
subsidiären schutz zugesprochen bekommen
das hat mir heute früher der
bundesinnenminister bestätigt dass dampf
hat das ausdrücklich noch einmal
nachrecherchiert das amt ausdrücklich
bestätigt dass dem betroffenen der
sogenannten subsidiären schutz nach § 4
asylgesetz zugesprochen wurde
stimmt es dass der täter immer wieder
von unterkunft zu unterkunft verlegt
worden ist auch mal in u haft war und
wieder freigelassen wurde und wohnen
diese psychiatrische auffälligkeit zu
behandeln hofft dass mir jetzt keine
bekannt und mir ist auch nicht bekannt
da angehen
und diese traumatisierung oder diese
psychiatrische belastung quasi von dem
täter war die bekannt und wurde aber
nicht weiter verfolgt nicht behandelt
die psychiatrische auffälligkeit war wie
kranke ist von den streifenbeamten hier
beispielsweise bei diesem vorfall im
juni auch angenommen worden weil sie
einfach zu dem ergebnis graben aufgrund
des ablaufes und des gesprächs mit ihm
das war psychischer auffälligkeiten
vorhanden sind
er hat sich einfach vor fahrzeug
gestellt der musste dann anhalten ist
dann auf der beifahrerseite gegangen und
das angestiegen und sagt fans mich bitte
in dem fall fans ins ausland und es ist
natürlich ein verhalten das aufwändig
ist aber jetzt nicht irgendwo in dem
stil war es trotzdem eingewiesen worden
von der stadt würzburg und dann geprüft
werden von den ärzten und die kam zu dem
ergebnis ist jetzt keine fremd und keine
selbst gefährlichkeit und dann wird er
wieder freigelassen
das interessant war es bekannt aber es
ist geprüft wurden ergebnis und momentan
haben wir jetzt was man bisher wissen
aber wir werden dann natürlich die
ermittlungen weiterführen keinerlei
anlass daran zu zweifeln
der ablauf ist einer wie ihn leider
immer wieder leben bei diesem vorfall
jetzt mit im auge als einfach
manche menschen verhaltensweisen an den
tag legen die psychische aufwendig sind
und dann wir haben mehrere hundert
einweisungen nach den trieben
krankenhilfe gesetzen macht man sich da
jetzt vorwürfe dass dass der mann wieder
freigelassen wurde quasi auf freien fuß
gesetzt obwohl er ja nicht psychisch
unbelastet war nach nach dem vorfall im
juni letzten jahres
aber jetzt günstig den ersten noch nicht
verstanden vorwürfe weil man sich jetzt
vorwürfe macht das dass der mann jetzt
auf freiem fuß war nach dem ja
eigentlich letztes jahr im juni so etwas
vorgefallen
bevor man fordert wir machen müssen wir
erstmal genau prüfen und der sache
nachgehen also an dem fall mit den daten
die ich jetzt
bisher habe aus dem was damals
schriftlich dass gehalten worden ist ist
ja nicht so dass noch nichts gemacht
worden ist man hat ja gehandelt kann ich
momentan keinen vorwurf machen aber muss
weiter geprüft werden man muss noch mal
hinterfragen man muss noch mal schauen
man muss mit den ärzten dann auch noch
mal sprechen was die dann veranlasst hat
und was sich jeweils ergeben hat und wir
müssen wir auch sehen das ja außer den
vorfällen die wir ihnen jetzt
vorgetragen haben wir haben wir alle
unsere unterlagen geprüft war der
polizei haben wir nur noch ja einige
verlust und kunst anzeigen letztendlich
über die ganzen jahre hinweg es wird da
war weiter bisher bei uns nichts
registriert und das alles noch mal
aufräumen noch mal hinterfragen und dann
schauen wir ob noch was dazu kommt ob
neue erkenntnisse dazu kommen und dann
kann abwehren
man muss in dem zusammenhang auch
betonen dass das festhalten gegen den
willen eines patienten nur bei selbst
und fremdgefährdung möglich ist da kann
man nichts ist mehr freiheitsberaubung
wenn man den dabehalten würdig gegen
sande
es wird grundsätzlich jeder vorfall den
wir jetzt bisher registriert haben mit
ihnen wird noch mal angeschaut
das ist routine nicht nur bei diesem
fall sondern bei so gravierenden
auswirkungen ist das standard bei der
bayerischen polizei und hängt zusammen
mit der gründlichen aufarbeitung und
haben sich jetzt auch leute gemeldet die
seien ja wir haben den schon mehrfach
auch in der stadt erleben auffällig da
ist man natürlich erstmal vorsichtig
immer haben die leute wirklich den
richtigen identifiziert und ja um eine
frau hat wohl auch gesagt sie habe
polizei darauf hingewiesen und
also hat sich mitteilungen auch gekriegt
ist das bekannte also auch den drachen
gehen wir natürlich nach welche vorfälle
sind gegebenenfalls überhaupt noch nicht
gemeldet worden oder noch nicht
registriert worden
und wir haben heute nacht natürlich auch
im rahmen des geschehens mitteilungen
bekommen
da muss auch ines mal überprüft werden
ist es die person auch letztendlich auch
im austausch mit behörden bei den von
der stadt bedburg kam da hinweise
das ist auch ganz normale erfahrung dass
wir so unsere vielen hinweise kommen und
die müssen jetzt überprüft werden aber
es die person dann auch noch und zwar
spricht dafür dass es die person war und
dann werden diese fälle natürlich auch
bewertet überhaupt keine frage
denkt es reicht
völkerling bild zeitung viele würzburger
mit denen ich gesprochen habe hatten
heute auch den respekt vor den menschen
die gestern eingegriffen haben doch mal
bekundet und hatten ein detail
rausgestellt wo sie gesagt haben das
waren wohl auch selber migranten können
sie das bestätigen dass also auch die
leute die da wirklich
mit stühlen und so weiter auf dem
losgegangen sind in die enge getrieben
haben dass die auch teilweise in
migrantischen migrationshintergrund
haben haben wir keine kenntnisse zur
diese ermittlungen die wir führen geht
natürlich erstmal in richtung aufklärung
der tat
sicher werden wir natürlich auch bürger
die sich hier besonders hervorgetan
haben
zum schutz der anderen natürlich auch
noch prüfen und eruieren und vielleicht
auch für entsprechende belohnungen
dankschreiben et cetera vorsehen
aber das ist natürlich jetzt nicht
primär gegenstand der ermittlungen und
ich kann zum jetzigen zeitpunkt noch
nicht sagen
wie viele diese bürger haben momentan
haben die hier aktiv tätig worden ich
bin aber davon überzeugt dass die
vernehmungen gemacht worden sind diesen
punkt natürlich auch abdecken
zwei schnelle fragen an sie hat
bürgermeister eine frage vielleicht
haben sie das auch vergessen oder schon
gesagt die familien erhalten ja
sicherlich alle erdenklichen hilfen von
seiten der stadt sicherlich oder ja im
moment ist es natürlich erst einmal das
thema der begleitung der familien
letzten acht im grunde auch die
information dass ist enorm rahmen unter
leitung der polizei auch erfolgt und die
stadt ist natürlich unterstützend mit
ihren sozialen einrichtungen und
beratungen im grunde mit dabei und an
den herrn minister
sie merken ja wie die entwicklung in der
gesellschaft rasant voran geht auch was
aggressionen betrifft oder gestern auch
bei uns in der stadt ich habe es auch
erst abends erfahren
in anderen stadtvierteln hatte man ja
nichts mitbekommen da können das leben
einfach so weiter gibt es überlegungen
bei ihnen im ministerium dass sich die
leute beruhigen herr oberstaatsanwalt ja
der hat vorhin mal geantwortet wie ein
mensch der stadt derek hat gesagt von
einem glatten durchschuss das ist jäger
jägersprache glatter durchschuss gibt es
da überlegungen oder hilfen auch in den
zentren nicht um beute zu machen aber
dass man prophylaktisch arbeitet und
dass die gesellschaft beruhigt wird also
nicht durch strengere maßnahmen sondern
im sinne eines dialoges aggressionen
abbauen das ist nur eine höfliche frage
also ohne experte
in all den fragen zu sein behauptete ich
glaube dadurch muss sagen auch die ärzte
weil das zum ausdruck bringt dass in dem
fall ist geschoss nicht mehr im körper
steckt
gleichzeitig damit er auch zum ausdruck
kommt dass in der regel wenn man das so
sagt keine ansonsten was soll die
lebensgefährlichen verletzungen was ich
an blutgefäßen oder gleichen damit
verbunden sind
also das war denke ich eine völlig
richtige aussage und mit verlaub nochmal
ich betone ausdrücklich wir haben ja
auch schon andere fälle gehabt und es
gibt situationen wo ich auch verstehen
haben wo polizisten in notwehr handeln
dass sie dann nicht mehr sicher sein
können dass sie nicht eben auch ein
lebenswichtiges organ treffen und
darüber habe ich auch gestern schon
darauf hingewiesen dass das nochmal
das ist schulbuchmäßig das auf die beine
eines schwerverbrechers geschossen wird
und auf die weise ihn zu stoppen aber
letztlich damit nicht sein leben zu
gefährden
also da gibt es meines erachtens an
diesen aussagen wirklich nichts
auszusetzen
ansonsten ist dieses thema natürlich der
verbalen forum der cola die zunehmende
polarisierung in unsere gesellschaft der
radikalisierung von teilen der
gesellschaft ist natürlich ein ständiges
thema wir haben darüber schon zahlreiche
fachkongresse in münchen und an anderen
orten zu diesen themen in den letzten
jahren durchgeführt wir haben das thema
wenn ich an wenn ja was denn jetzt
gerade im letzten wochen wieder
beschäftigt hat
antisemitismus nach dem gaza israel
krieg etc
wir haben die diskussion über mehr ja
letztendlich auch interreligiösen dialog
wie wir hier entsprechend versuchen
können konflikte abzubauen und zu einem
friedlichen zusammenlebens beizutragen
das ist mir nicht nur sagen
sicherheitsminister sondern auch
integrationsminister das ist uns ein
ständiges thema er arbeite ständig daran
auch unter beteiligung vieler
betroffenen da weiter zu arbeiten und
uns macht es natürlich besorgt und das
will ich schon an dieser stelle auch
noch mal sagen das leider so großartig
die ganze entwicklung des internet ist
so eindrucksvoll die ganze entwicklung
der social media ist werde ich schon
spüren dass sie leider auch im radikalen
bereich schon sehr stark auch gebrauch
oder missbraucht wird wie sie wohl und
das erleben wäre wenn der
rechtsextremistische taten in den
letzten jahren auch in deutschland
beobachten das erleben wir im
islamistischen bereich des erlegen war
querfeldein das beschäftigt uns alle und
so wird noch in bayern das sind themen
die auf bundesebene diskutiert werden
wir haben gerade auch in der
innenministerkonferenz in der letzten
woche in baden württemberg auch wieder
über solche themen geredet
also das ist ein thema und der
beschäftigen wir uns natürlich auch
ständig damit und gleichwohl wissen wir
dass wir trotzdem wahrscheinlich bei
bestem bemühen nicht eben jede gewalttat
werden verhindern können auch wenn wir
noch dazu im moment jetzt ja noch gar
nicht endgültig wissen was das
ausschlaggebende motiv war
für den bayerischen rundfunk unsere
gedanken sind bei den opfern vor allem
auch bei den schwerverletzten
können sie uns da sagen wie es den
aktuell geht hat wie man die opferliste
von euch auch noch martin ja wir hatten
ja sieben schwerverletzte von denen sind
mittlerweile nachbehandlung zwei
personen aus der klinik entlassen worden
war einer person besteht nach wie vor
akute lebensgefahr
alle anderen verletzten sind
mittlerweile ärztlich stabilisiert
ja frauen unter jungen
die örtlichkeiten sind das volk
natürliches baden württemberg und umland
von salzburger als bauer meint asiaten
vorhin erklärt dass nach diesem vorfall
wo er sich vor die sichere gestellt hat
er ja nach unseren recherchen
offensichtlich eine nach dem zentrum für
seelische gesundheit verbracht hat was
ist denn passiert nach dieser ersten
geschichte wo er offenbar zumindest mit
einem messer gedroht hat aber ich jetzt
auch akustisch nicht genau gehört hat
vor allem an
sie hatten erzählt von der von diesem
vorfall wo er sich vorgestellt hat bitte
hier
nach unseren recherchen ist ja deswegen
vom 15 juni im zentrum seelische
gesundheit der gewissen wo er sich dann
war die selbst entlassen hat am nächsten
tag für weil auch die ärzte keine eigen-
und fremdgefährdung sagen ich würde
jetzt interessieren was bei diesem
ersten vorfall anschließend passierte wo
er wohl mit einem messer getötet hat bei
den ärzten vorfall mit der bedrohung die
staatsanwaltschaft nur sagen ja ihr habt
da kann ich berichten dass die
staatsanwaltschaft würzburg wegen dieses
ersten vorfalls im januar ein
strafrechtliches ermittlungsverfahren
gegen den beschuldigten führt in dessen
rahmen eine psychiatrische begutachtung
in auftrag gegeben wurde
das psychiatrische gutachten liegt noch
nicht vor
also das ermittlungsverfahren ist bei
uns weiterhin anhängig
einmal warum dauert das so lange seit
januar und zum zweiten gestern gestern
hieß es es gebe einen kleinen jungen
dessen vater verstorben sei wenn ich sie
jetzt richtig verstanden habe ist dieser
vater am leben ist das anders ist es der
schwerverletzte oder wie geht es ihm
also der erste teil warum es so lange
dauert es hat im rahmen dieses
ermittlungsverfahrens zunächst eine
anschriften überprüfung stattgefunden
das heißt man hat geschaut ob der
beschuldigte tatsächlich in dieser
einrichtung auf rechtlich ist weil er
muss ja dann auch entsprechend für eine
psychiatrische begutachtung vorgeladen
werden
nachdem diese anschriften abklärung
erfolgt war
ist der auftrag an die sachverständige
erteilt worden und ja die erstellung
dauer von solchen gutachten die beträgt
schon einige wochen bis monate ganz
einfach deshalb weil die
sachverständigen in aller regel erst mal
vor befunde anfordern wenn solche
vorliegen
sie lesen die akten sie bestellen den
beschuldigten für eine entsprechende
untersuchung 1 führten gespräche
es wären oftmals psychologische zusatz
tests gemacht also die erstellung eines
solchen gutachtens nimmt eben eine
entsprechende zeit in anspruch
naja wenn sie mal rechnen
die tat war mitte januar wir haben jetzt
mitte juni
die akten sind zunächst mal zu uns
gekommen anfang mitte februar von der
polizei nachdem die entsprechenden
zeugen vernehmungen durchgeführt wurden
ja also fünf monate insgesamt seit der
tat uns wieder die beiden frage gestern
die nacht hat es tatsächlich einmal
kurze zeit geheißen dass ein mann
getötet worden wäre
das war eine falsche bewertung bei der
ersten begutachtung oder beim ersten
augenscheinnahme aufgrund neu sind
auswählt
der in lebensgefahr schwebt ist eine
frau
wenn ja mit stahl von der main post ich
wollte noch mal nach der durchsuchung
fragen nach dem ergebnis da hatten sie
noch angesprochen es wurden
handschriften gefunden die noch
ausgewertet werden einige medien
sprechen schon von konkret von isis
propagandamaterial wenn ich es richtig
verstanden habe können sie das noch
nicht bestätigen oder kann man da sagen
dass beispielsweise durch entsprechende
symbolik auf dem material oder ähnliches
ein hinweis zumindest besteht das kann
ich momentan noch nicht bestätigen
wir prüfen das noch und wir müssen
natürlich auch immer
sehen sind die materialien die hier
aufgefunden worden sind haben die tat
bezug oder nicht
der mittelwert wie vor ihn
gut ja jetzt höre ich mich auch gerade
den hasen auch vom bayerischen rundfunk
noch eine nachfrage die in die ähnliche
richtung geht ob der täter mit irgendwas
bekannt ist dass er mit al shabab
sympathisiert hat also momentan laufen
die ermittlungen noch die ersten
ermittlungen wurden natürlich die vier
geführt um die tötungsdelikte
nachzuweisen um die vorführung zu
ermöglichen
jetzt mit einstieg des
landeskriminalamtes wird die politische
dimension ob so eine vorliegt oder nicht
hier geprüft
momentan kann man da weder dafür noch
dagegen sprechen das muss man abwarten
was die ermittlungen des
landeskriminalamtes diesbezüglich
ergeben
ja dann darf ich sie oder darf ich in
die runde fragen gibt es noch weitere
fragen
das ist nicht der fall dann darf ich sie
dennoch darauf hinweisen dass die
möglichkeit besteht noch eine kurze
selbst schwer verletzte oder sieben
schwerverletzte dass wir das noch mal
genau updaten und da nicht irgendwas
falsches verbreiten
es wird schwer und ein leichtverletzter
und zwei von denen sie nicht mehr im
krankenhaus oder sind das die sind alle
sieben noch im krankenhaus
22 personen zählt nicht mehr
und dann noch eine frage zur zur mutter
des kindes die lebt oder ist die auch
unter den toten
die mutter des
ob gespräche die mutter die mutter des
verletzten kindes ist die unter den
toten
von apa ja ja dann vielen dank es
besteht jetzt im anschluss die
möglichkeit zu bekommen
wir hätten in zweifel